the automobile has remained largely
unchanged for over a hundred years at
Apple we thought how can we set up
introducing Apple car what you first
notice when you sit in Apple car is that
there's no wheel or pedals Siri does all
the driving for you by using Apple maps
to take the most efficient route every
time you'll be gliding through back
streets with all the ease of an Apple
lawyer gliding through corporate tax
loopholes series take me to Cupertino
now driving you to the bottom that makes
superior crafted unapologetically in
styrofoam Apple car can be personalized
with a range of apologetic silicon
covers that elegantly snap-on
to protect Apple cars most important
feature Bono who will sit in the
backseat and play every u2 song on loop
for the life of the car the windscreen
itself is made from sapphire crystal
which is a thousand times stronger than
glass unless something touches it
like most Apple products Apple car
doesn't crash and if it does crash it's
probably because of user error Apple car
wouldn't be an Apple product if it had
windows so we got rid of them and
replace them with gorgeous retina
displays when it comes to looking at
your surroundings the passenger is
always in the driver's seat if you're
driving around Silicon Valley and you
don't want to see homeless people simply
swipe them away oh look a harmonious
multiracial picnic yeah that's nice
Apple car is fully electric and with
apples crap tech engine it can drive
continuously for 24 minutes a day on a
single charge and there's enough onboard
storage to hide as many chinese workers
that have committed suicide during the
assembly of the car which is four and
that's three more than any other car
Apple car represents the most important
most magical most revolutionary
and genuinely exciting automotive
industry innovation since the built in
iPhone charger
[Music]